I love you honey I love you too okay I
love you like I love TV I love you like
I love pizza stop when you go home do
you look around and wonder where did I
even come from mother those are not the
same breasts you nursed us with you got
Bionic breasts
you want to hear story I think we should
just stay I think we got to hear this
well this is the this is the female form
she's got in her boobies to subject and
they are so perky oh yeah yeah yeah two
fingers inside and just a girlfriend
it's a perfectly normal thing for two
human beings first if I was gay
[Music]
Lester you gonna spill beer on the couch
we're going to suffer Marilyn it's just
a divorce
relax relax the leaders of Japan sister
we sisters been to a lot she's not
listening to me that ice cream in your
mouth and you are in very very very big
trouble I am NOT going to say it again
not you
like a nail on my deck life in bed let
me learn and that 1/16 and I thought you
and my mother to you were Jeffrey Dahmer
good luck yeah I'm sorry
to circle a life everybody let's go all
men
[Music]